some of the biggest franchises and video
gaming are getting long-awaited sequels
in 2017 including Mass Effect and
Resident Evil but one title is still
conspicuously absent from the release
schedule Elder Scrolls here's a look at
why we haven't seen Elder Scrolls 6
Skyrim remastered elderscrolls v Skyrim
was one of the most popular games of its
generation so fans were pretty excited
when the games developer and publisher
Bethesda released a new remastered
version in October 2016
to celebrate Skyrim's 5th anniversary
but if you are frustrated that the
studio was using its resources to
remaster Elder Scrolls 5 instead of
working on Elder Scrolls 6 there's some
good news studios frequently use
remastering old games as a way to
fine-tune the game engine for a new
installment Capcom did it with Resident
Evil and Naughty Dog did it with
uncharted so there's a good chance that
the remastered Skyrim is actually a
stepping stone towards Elder Scrolls 6
Skyrim is still popular while many games
like evolve and titanfall can die out
over time due to diminishing player
bases Skyrim is still going strong
in fact even five years after its
release Skyrim is still one of the top
20 PC games on Steam one big reason for
this is that Professor has embraced
modding by the player community
encouraging fan participation to keep
gameplay fresh and vital and as long as
Skyrim is still popular it takes the
pressure off Bethesda allowing them to
take their sweet time perfecting every
detail of Elder Scrolls 6 before they
release it bethesda takes it slow but
festa isn't a studio that likes to rush
their games the studio was built of a
sense of trust with their fans and
Bethesda won't be pressured to release
Elder Scrolls 6 until they are satisfied
with the game the fester honcho Ted
Howard said as much at e3 2016 we think
very long-term we're not a developer
that's going to rush something like this
out when you think about what is a
future of that kind of game you have a
pretty good idea of what that's going to
be that attention to detail is one
reason fallout 4 took 7 years to make
and that's why the companies in no rush
to finish Elder Scrolls 6 Elder Scrolls
online it's important to also keep in
mind that Bethesda did release a new
Elder Scrolls game in the year since
gyeom's launched in 2014 fans got their
hands on Elder Scrolls online developed
by Bethesda's corporate cousin ZeniMax
online studios the Elder Scrolls MMO was
itself in the works for seven long years
as everyone insisted on the highest
level of quality control to ensure it
lived up to the Elder Scrolls franchise
reputation and since then the game has
seen a regular release of new content
with six TLC packs so far and Counting
so it's not like they're just sitting
around doing nothing
technical difficulties one big reason
for the delay is the simple fact that
Skyrim was created to be compatible with
the previous generations of consoles you
know your PlayStation 3 and Xbox 360
while Elder Scrolls 6 is presumably
being developed for the current
generation that probably won't sit well
with the game's legion of PC players but
there is a benefit to the advance in
technology as it will allow developers
to build the game at a higher level for
everyone that is once they have the
technology to make the game in the first
place which they currently don't
according to Todd Howard I could excited
here and explain the game to you and you
would say that sounds like you don't
even have the technology that is going
to take a lot of time what we have in
mind for that game the studio has other
projects so with Bethesda doesn't even
have the technology to make Elder
Scrolls 6 yet just what are they doing
with that time well according to Howard
we actually have two other large
projects we're also doing that are
bigger than anything we've done and what
you people will probably hear about
those even before elders roll 6 that's
great news for fans of Bethesda and
video games in general but not so great
for fans dying to see Elder Scrolls 6
anytime soon
when will Elder Scrolls 6 come out even
the people working at Bethesda can't
seem to agree on when Elder Scrolls 6
will show up in front of gamers faces in
fact there seems to be some debate over
whether or not they're even working on
the game at all executive producer Todd
Howard certainly seem to think so when
he was asked about it at e3 in 2016 are
you guys gonna do in Elder Scrolls 6 I
mean that's kind of like the elephant in
the room always when we talk about
anything and you know I think it's good
in these moments to tell our fans yes if
you know of course we are um you know
it's something we love but it is you
know I have to be careful is it
however just two weeks later but
Fester's had to pee
Pete Hines took to Twitter to tell
everyone that they actually aren't
working on Elder Scrolls 6 at all
claiming that Howard's comments were
misconstrued as for now the only thing
we can be sure of is that everybody once
Elder Scrolls 6 to come out and nobody
knows when it will hopefully the whole
franchise hasn't taken an arrow in the
knee I used to be an adventurer like you
and I took an arrow in the knee
gaah what an awful joke please end me
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to my youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]